c'est un week end ordinaire pour les
femmes centrafricaines dans la capitale
bangui elles sont nombreuses à faire les
courses l'air de rien et pourtant
nombreuses garde en elle les séquelles
d'une guerre qui dure depuis déjà près
de dix ans les violences physiques et
sexuelles font partie du quotidien de
certaines de ces femmes et pour leur
venir en aide
l' ong médecins sans frontières a lancé
ce samedi 17 avril un programme de prise
en charge
l'association générale des réflexions
qui viennent vers nous effectivement
elles sont venues dans un état vraiment
très inquiétant parce que vous savez que
les pions c'est naturellement pour
moitié et tous les régimes qui viennent
guerre ne sont souvent très traumatisée
et dès qu'ils sont venus vers nous par
notre ce contrat puis on a vu qu'il ya
vraiment un changement radical dans
l'eure
depuis juillet jusqu'à fin novembre
maintenir
nous avons reçu de 174 personnes
majoritairement des femmes jeu
aussi cet homme et 24 mineurs en général
pas dans un très bon état puisque
[Musique]
c'est psychologique ainsi que violences
des souvent dans un contexte de menaces
sylvie et rose font partie de ces
victimes de violences sexuelles
un visage couvert elles ont accepté de
témoigner
j'étais reparti chez moi en 2013 pour
prendre des affaires pour mon bébé et
des musulmans armés du pk5 mon prix on
couchait avec moi avant d'enfoncer un
bâton dans mon sexe je ne connaissais
personne parmi eux
je n'ai pu porter l affaire en justice
je suis seulement venu ici à l'hôpital
c'était le 11 décembre 2013 que cela
m'est arrivé ce sont des scellés cas qui
sont arrivés en grand nombre dans un
véhicule en tirant dans toutes les
directions
le mari de ma grande soeur avaient fui
ma grande soeur en les entendant aussi a
fui j'ai été tourmenté par les tirs et
lorsque j'ai essayé de fuir ils m'ont
pris ils m'ont violée et ont pillé la
maison en prenant de l'argent et des
téléphones ils ont tout ramasser et ont
fait plusieurs tirs avant de partir
toujours d'après médecins sans
frontières il est fréquent que les
agressions soient commises par des
personnes appartenant à l'entourage des
victimes
plus de la moitié des personnes prises
en charge déclarent connaître leurs
agresseurs